ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president & Co creative director arcade
Studios raphaël colantonio
thank you hi everyone I'm very excited
to be here tonight on behalf of Arkane
studios the makers of Dishonored our
passion is for a very specific kind of
game first-person immersive games our
games blend narration and simulation in
a way that makes every player's
experience different where players can
improvise and where choices of
consequence our games encourage replay
in order to try different play styles so
that players are free to play their own
way
in 2012 we released Dishonored we were
thrilled that the game was so well
received by the gamers and the critics
all around the world that was like one
of the best feeling for for us
developers after that launch my friend
and co directive director Harvey Smith
took the lead on this one too so he went
to france in lyon and worked with the
team over there
meanwhile I have been busy in Austin
working on something else with the team
in Austin and tonight I have a surprise
for you I'm going to reveal what that
surprise is in a minute it's a new game
built on the values that are so dear to
our Cain it's another first-person
immersive game set in a dangerous
universe only this time we've added a
psychological thriller here is the
world's first look at what we've been up
to good morning Morgan
today is Monday March 15 20 30 - you
have a 9:00 a.m. appointment with Alex
in his office there is no duration set
meeting there is a three p.m. meeting
and Transtar conference room a to
green-light research and development
plans
prior to arrival
good morning Morgan
today is Monday March 15 20 30 - you
have a 9:00 a.m. appointment with Alex
good morning Morgan
today is Monday March 15 2013
good morning Moore looks like we have
some tests to run through today
good morning Morgan
you're not going to like what I have to
say next
in pray you awaken abort tells one a
very special Space Station it is year
2032 you are the key subject of an
experiment meant to outer humanity
forever but things have gone wrong of
course the space station has been
overrun by an alien threat and you are
now being hunted as you dig into the
dark secrets of tellus one and your own
past you must survive using all the
tools at your disposal onboard of the
station your wits weapons and
mind-bending abilities
prey will be will be available next year
on Xbox one ps4 and PC we'll have more
to show at the quake on so be sure to
join us there thank you hi everyone I'm
Marty